as far as self-improvement in getting
after it goes whose standard should one
measure themselves by so who do I use as
a standard to measure myself by it's
it's really everyone and no one because
there's people in the world that have
skills and strength and talent that I
will never have Oh reading some of these
notions that you can be whatever you
want to be is as long as you want it bad
enough those are not true
there are fairy tales we all have
limitations and I don't have the right
genes to be an Olympic weightlifting
champion I don't have the right genetics
to be an Olympic champion sprinter or a
gymnast or whatever sport you want a
name now sure if I trained my whole life
perhaps I could have achieved some high
level in those sports but I can tell you
I do not have the DNA to be the best in
the world in those categories so what
does that mean does that mean that I
give up does that mean that I quit of
course not not at all it means that I'm
gonna try to be the best that I can be
the strongest the fastest the smartest
the smartest human that I can become
that's what I'm gonna go for and I will
I will compare myself to others and and
look at them and see what they're doing
and I'll say
that it is possible how close can I get
to that greatness how close can I get to
that glory but the reality is that my
glory it doesn't happen in front of a
crowd it doesn't happen in a stadium it
doesn't happen on a stage
there's no medals handed out my glory
happens in the darkness of the early
morning in solitude alone where I try
and I try and I try again to be
everything that I possibly can be the
best that I possibly can be better than
I was yesterday and better than other
people thought I could be faster and
stronger and smarter and with one
victory that no one can ever take away
from me a victory that is earned every
single day a victory of determination
and will and discipline and a victory
that is achieved because I will not stop